[Music]
hey everyone
welcome to another installment of harry
potter theory
in today's video we're once again going
to be discussing french
bobaton student fleur de you guys seem
to really be enjoying getting to know
her character
so i thought i'd oblige and continue to
make content covering her
when fleur is first introduced as a
fierce competitor in the triwizard
tournament
she showed up at hogwarts positively
unimpressed with her surroundings
when she walked in the room the most
obvious thing about her was that she was
strikingly beautiful
but she also gave off a very pompous
arrogant vibe
however when harry goes on to save her
little sister gabrielle
during task 2 of the triwizard
tournament something which fleur herself
failed to do blur's tone changed quite a
bit dropping the
icy attitude and even going on to become
friends with harry
now for those that have only seen the
films you probably don't know fleur
very well at all so most of these things
are going to be news to you
as for the book readers i'm willing to
bet there are still a few things that
you didn't know
either way sit back relax and enjoy my
top 8 interesting facts about fleur
de la cour number one her heritage
though fleur looks almost completely
human
she actually has one quarter velar blood
running through her veins
for those unaware villa are semi-human
magical beings
beautiful women with white cold hair and
skin that appears to shine
moon bright when angry villa take on a
less pleasant appearance
their faces elongate into sharp cruel
beaked bird heads
and long scaly wings burst from their
shoulders and this is partially what
makes velas
so enigmatic as where in one moment they
can exude sheer beauty
and the very next moment they can turn
into horrific monsters
harry sees this first hand at this the
velar lost control
instead of dancing they launched
themselves across the field and began
throwing what seemed to be handfuls of
fire at the leprechauns
watching through his omnioculars harry
saw that they didn't look remotely
beautiful
now the beauty of wheelers enchants men
who come across them
and despite fleur only being one quarter
wheeler it was evident that her beauty
had an impact on the boys of hogwarts
number two her wand next up we have
fleur's wand
now in harry potter everyone has a wand
unique to them so no surprises there
but among all of the possible one
combinations in the wizarding world
fleur's is still pretty unique yes nine
and a half inches
inflexible rosewood and containing dear
me
an heir from the end of avila one of my
grandmothers
you see fleur's wand possessed an
ancestral element
a familial component vela hair when flow
was young her grandmother gave her the
hair that was eventually placed into her
wand
though powerful the hair of avila makes
the wand very inflexible
as well as exceedingly hard to control
if you think about it
this actually fits fleur quite well
number three
her beauty being a quarter wheeler
beauty is an important part of fleur's
character
it's described constantly and because of
her heritage it almost transcends
the traditional idea of beauty
everything about her turns heads
and this is because villa possessed
beauty sort of akin to the
sirens of different mythologies an
alluring
irresistible type of beauty but one
really interesting thing about vela
is that they don't completely steal the
show with their beauty
in fact when they're in a positive
emotional state themselves
they're able to make those around them
seem more beautiful as well
while she was getting married to bill
fleur was well and truly happy
and it was at this moment that harry
noticed that even bill
started looking better and better
despite rocking a face full of scars
it would seem that the beauty of vila
has the ability to emanate
and affect others to some extent number
four she worked at gringotts
from 1995 to 1997 starting in the summer
of 95
fleur secured a part-time job at
gringotts gringotts which is operated
primarily by goblins
is the only wizarding bank in that part
of the world despite being french
fleur's proficiency at speaking english
which developed as time went on
allowed her to work in this setting it
was at gringotts that fleur became
reacquainted with bill weasley
the eldest weasley child bill who worked
as a curse breaker for the bank
had returned from egypt and secured a
desk job at which point bill and fleur
started dating
after dating for a brief period bill
recognized that he was madly in love
prompting him to propose the two got
married shortly thereafter
number five molly and ginny hated her
after bill proposed to fleur
he wanted her to better know his family
which prompted their extended visit to
the borough in the summer of 1996
however it wasn't long before fleur made
a negative impression on the matron of
the home
molly as well as the weasley daughter
jenny bill is very busy at the moment
working very hard and i only work
part-time at gringotts for my english
so he brought me here for a few days to
get to know his family properly
i was so pleased to hear you would be
coming there isn't much to do here
unless you like cooking and chickens you
see flo was very proud of her heritage
and her background and this comes across
in her demeanor to a certain degree
she was also very outspoken a good
example of this was when she visited
hogwarts for the triwizard tournament
as during her first visit she made a bit
of a habit of complaining about the
school
constantly comparing it to her own
school bobaton
she showed similar behavior when
visiting the borough comparing it to her
own home
and it was this stoppage behavior that
the weasley women picked up on
however it wasn't all on fleur the
weasley women also unfairly judged her
by her looks
categorizing her to fit the dumb blonde
stereotype
ginny even had her nickname for fleur
phlegm
fortunately molly and ginny did
eventually realize their mistake of
being too harsh
on fleur this came after fleur
demonstrated her loyalty to bill
following his debilitating injuries
inflicted at the hands of fenrir
greyback
when fleur stayed with bill after his
appearance changed as a result of his
injuries
it became clear that her relationship
with him wasn't just superficial or
physical
they truly were compatible number six
children
it should come as no surprise that bill
and fleur after getting married
went on to have children of their own
fleur became the mother of three
children
victoire louis and dominique weasley
expanding the already prolific weasley
clan even more
given that both victoire and dominique
were female
and that fleur had velar blood in her
veins her daughters also possessed velar
blood
this made them 1 8 vela technically
louis had the same blood in him but it
has been reinforced through canon that
velas are only women
number seven nurse-like tendencies
though she was not trained as a nurse
it seems like time and time again fleur
jumped in to provide medical assistance
to anyone that needed it when bill was
savaged by fenrir greyback
she cared for him exceedingly well
similarly when others like ollivander
grip hook hermione ron harry etc needed
medical assistance
she always took them in and cared for
them fleur pulled her heart into caring
for people when they needed it
and i have no doubt in my mind that
fleur also possessed an above average
understanding
of healing magic number eight special
magical abilities
i've mentioned a few of them already
like her ability to emanate and
spread beauty as well as her ability to
help people heal
however flow had a lot more abilities
than that perhaps most notably fleur was
considerably talented at producing
charms
such as the ingenious bubble head charm
that she utilized in the triwizard
tournament
later in life fleur also developed a
knack for performing household magic
much like her mother-in-law molly with
already very strong maternal instincts
these spells helped fleur to cook and
clean though flo was often preoccupied
with caring for people
she still had an edge and was a talented
duelist she was not one to cross
and that's it for this video whether
you're a book reader film goer or both
i hope you learned something new about
fleur de la cor if you guys enjoy this
type of video i'd be happy to do it for
other characters
just let me know in the comment section
below until next time
remember it is our choices that show
what we truly are
far more than our abilities